cuando mi mamá iba a cruzarme para el
colegio y se estrella yo me he quedado
pensando qué carajos hace la gente
mientras se sometía aquí 84
que están haciendo mi mamá que están
haciendo yo sino tiene que estar aquí
ocho a cuatro
viviendo viviendo porque si yo hubiera
querido estar ahí 84 probablemente nunca
se me ocurren esas preguntas pues si yo
no quería estar ahí me sentía como una
cárcel constantemente en el hambre y
vierta el tiempo
siempre tuve curiosidad del mundo afuera
porque nunca aprendí porque tenemos que
seguir un currículum y darle un espacio
mientras todo se seguridad afuera yo
quería hacer música y pintar por eso nos
presentamos en el colegio porque no
podía como encasillarme todo esto que
estaba dicho y que tocaba hacer
después de estar una hora y media por la
mañana dormida probablemente siempre
estaba al colegio
llegaba el día del coliseo en el
futbolito con la guitarra a tocar todo
el día y apuntar de una amiga y
estábamos ahí todo el día
y hay un momento personalmente tenía que
comer entonces llegar me encontraba hijo
a un profesor con el que ha tenido clase
y pues yo mientras se preguntaba por qué
yo no estaba en clase
ese día me inventaba alguna cosa como
esta de la cita médica lo cual
obviamente jamás me dice pero yo no vine
a agregarles esto tiene las capacidades
de mentir sino a contarles cómo si no
cumplir exitosamente los parámetros del
sistema educativo y no acá la
universidad construye una carrera para
eso
y de la que nos preguntábamos a qué
vamos al colegio oa qué nos han dicho
que vamos al colegio más bien a aprender
las bases para ir a la universidad
después aprender las bases para
relacionarnos en una sociedad dispone se
aprenden las bases para tener un buen
trabajo
después a prepararnos para la vida
después porque la vida no es ya si no
después
ahora realmente aprendemos eso y cuando
salimos del colegio estamos más perdidos
que el perro porque no tenemos una idea
de cómo ejecutar todo eso que
supuestamente aprendimos y en medio de
los dolores de cabeza gastritis dolor de
espalda por cargar la maleta alergias
acá seguro tenemos todos mucho de
razones entonces a presionarme
sí no
pero si no damos el precio como
aprendemos
y creo que es importante que revisemos
la palabra aprendizaje que es obtener
conocimiento que el conocimiento como lo
tenemos todo es discutible y creo que
por eso siempre me cuestiono y me
cuestiono todavía porque creemos que ir
al colegio es la única manera de
aprender voy a hacer que nuestros niños
aprendan y conocer la verdad yo pienso y
esto hace mucho investigar sobre este
tema
no se siente un poco la verdad
sé que aparece aprendizaje sucede cuando
hay interés de por medio hay entusiasmo
al promedio hay una emoción así que toda
esta información se quede ahí
y que no solo se memorizan que al final
muchos estarán de acuerdo conmigo es lo
que vamos a en el colegio para pasar
exámenes luego olvidarnos de toda esa
información que aprendimos durante horas
para almacenar temporalmente nueva
información para el siguiente examen no
la pasamos en ese camino durante por lo
menos 11 años en el colegio
no tomaba clases de guitarra en la casa
y entonces yo quería aprender también
entonces pedí clases también con este
señor
a la segunda clase de usuario mamá que
de producto la guitarra no es domingo
que pronto porque por más interés que
tuviera me lo creí porque como nos han
enseñado los adultos saben más que los
niños
después de unos años éramos una banda de
rock con mi hermana y las amigas del
colegio donde yo tocaba batería porque
también instrumento efectivamente y de
zalla vamos todos los viernes después de
la jornada normal del colegio y nosotros
los seres humanos y me he dado cuenta
también en nuestras conversaciones y hoy
que tenemos un sentido de supervivencia
mental y emocional tan fuerte y tan
bonito que yo que convencí que vaya la
pena pasar todas esas horas estudiando
materias que odiaba sintiéndome
demasiado en félix haciendo tareas o al
menos fingiendo en desde las tareas para
pasar esas dos horas los viernes
estudiantes y haciendo música
después de un tiempo
descubrir en esos ensayos que me gustaba
mucho cantar pero pues ya va a la hora
de estar tocando batería y tratar de
afinar
entonces mi hermana es guitarrista y yo
llevaba 90 canto cantar de tracción del
combate y al canto es que sueña como un
poquito mejor en mi cabeza y así
hasta que un día obviamente se cansó y
demandarle el [ __ ] me dijo 'ven todo
enseñar los acordes aprende de luz y
sacar tus dos canciones y canta y
practica tú y yo vocal y si es verdad si
me senté práctico y bolton
y de ahí a hoy han pasado años de
práctica de presentar amigos que conozco
cómo se llama
cómo se hace qué es eso de solamente ver
y aprender lo que está lo que por fin
huyendo nunca en ese momento de mi día
no podría tener un profesor de guitarra
y desarrollar mi propia forma de
aprender de encontrar las herramientas
para tener el conocimiento que hoy tengo
es con el que vive
y sigo vendiendo todos los días porque
para mí ya no se trata de llegar a una
meta ya no digo ya no porque realmente
un momento solamente de que thor ya
después aprender por gusto y no por
obligación y esa frase a mí me revolví a
nosotros imagina lo que me generaba
porque yo no entendía que eso fuera
posible
entonces yo lo que para nosotros se
puede hacer sin darme cuenta que lo que
hacía para la música era precisamente
eso
pareciera que estoy en contra del
colegio cosas al respecto
pero si siento que los colegios tienen
que replantearse la manera en la que
abordan el aprendizaje entiendo que
aceptar un sistema de negocio que tiene
que cumplir con las estadísticas y los
exámenes y estas éstos se llaman estos
que hacen contra los colegios para qué
como para saber que el colegio está más
alto en los sistemas
así pérez de los niños donde están a que
le importan y sus pedido para pensar no
es su alimento el tema que los colegios
deban replantearse a los pactantes de no
más nos está olvidando saben a qué es lo
más importante
por eso yo creo que es más importante
que pensar en el colegio es preguntarles
como bocas lo siguiente
estamos dispuestos a respetar y apoyar
los intereses de nuestros hijos y genes
hacen las cosas que dicen disfrutar para
complacerlos a nosotros
y te pido lo que quiero ahora ellos en
su desarrollo o son libres de elegir
confiamos en ellos confiamos en nosotros
mismos
viene ahora la parte más importante de
la historia ofrece recordar de positiva
gracias
ella es julieta es mi hija tiene nueve
años y ella empezó la vida escolar como
muchos de nosotros no jardín colegio
otro colegio porque colegio
y cuando tenía seis años los demás eran
éstos van a decirnos que julieta estaba
teníamos que ponerlos a estudiar un poco
más porque debe pasar a segundo
entonces me falta una parte muy
importante y es que yo trabajé en esos
colegios y si trabajaron con ellos puedo
contarles todas estas ballenas de mi
experiencia escolar ya todo pero yo
siempre creí que podía hacer algo desde
aire y creo que no logren la mayoría del
tiempo
aunque
empecé a ver el funcionamiento interno
de los colegios que en ese momento del
nivel organice y ahora me acuerdo y me
alarmó un montón como tantos objetivos
que tocaba hacer comer a los niños
que el colegio final de colegio lo
bajaron otras dos papas que pudieran
estar por sus hijos no estaban si tantos
niños que llegaban de cosas materiales
para justificar todo ese tiempo que los
papás no estaban con ellos por estar
trabajando por su propio bien
ahora sí cuando oye está bastante lejos
y nosotros con mi esposo atentamente en
ver cómo hacer para ayudarla pensamos
que la forma de ser que era pasar a
segundo era estudiar más no porque entre
más horas de estudio más aprendida y ahí
empezó una maratón ridícula nos
levantamos una 5 de la mañana del último
ser desayuno repetía se llevaba la
verdad en la ruta así como un paquete
con medio de sal y notoria en la mano
no identificado con esa idea llegaba al
colegio luego llegaba a la casa canción
a 5 de la tarde súper cansada a tomar
onces hacer tareas
más porque tocaba pasar al segundo se
acostaba a las once de la noche llorando
y así pasamos del año
fue lo más innecesario que hemos hecho
después de entender que es ahorrar la
manera nos pusimos a investigar lo que
la otra forma
encontramos unos colegios alternativos
imparables realmente
y luego descubrimos el home school
ahí es una atención pues digamos que
además está de por medio entonces
planificábamos cada detalle de su día
con currículums en casa y juegos y de
todo y no tenía el tiempo para nada más
luego pasamos al colegio virtual que
terminó siendo casi la misma vaina
porque tampoco podía decir si lo quería
o no lo quería hacer un día porque está
nos pidió aprender sin currículo
entonces nosotros entramos en crisis
porque como carajos te dejamos de creer
a una línea de 8 años que podría
emprender sola
pero le creímos confiamos no fue fácil
porque nosotros no estamos acostumbrados
a confiar en los niños
en este momento vivimos aprendizaje
somos sus intereses pero tenemos
constantemente actividades pero no
imponemos nada tiene un parche de amigos
increíbles que he hecho esta región
con el que compartimos tantas
experiencias
porque eso estamos la vida ellas vive de
elegir viviendo ya no después
nosotros siempre la estamos acompañando
con esto yo no estoy diciendo que no sea
necesario sea alguien más para aprender
algo
valverde auto aprender de encontrar esos
conocimientos uno
si esto es nosotros tenemos la capacidad
de contar los caudillos en libros en
internet como sea por una persona un
amigo si un primo que sabe algo que tú
quieres entender y siempre cuestionar
todo busca esa información que te
interesa realmente aprender
este descontrol de nuestro conocimiento
y descubrir una autodisciplina increíble
que ha sido cortada siempre
quiero aclararles algo y es que yo no
siempre pude decidir ni cuándo ni cómo
hacer las cosas hace unos años de la
norma soltera sin trabajo que deberían
hablado de autoaprendizaje y libertades
me hubiera muerto la visa y
probablemente la persona que tenía
enfrente
pero que era porque me moría de miedo no
me creía capaz y también me
decidir es un privilegio
y creemos que su privilegio porque al
parecer solamente podemos decidir cuando
pasamos toda la vida que nos dicen que
tenemos que seguir y porque llega a su
preciado momento de decisión no nos
podemos equivocar
y eso es con super ansiedad y un miedo
terrible por eso ahora quiero contarles
una canción que estoy precisamente
pensando en eso en esos momentos
de miel en todos los niños que realmente
cargamos todos los días como fantasmas
porque dejarlos ir también es una
decisión sanar los es una decisión
bien
ah
[Música]
o dos
un camino entre rastro
[Música]
a mí
y toca el default al pasar de todo puede
repuntar
ésta recaiga aún puedo respirar
y aunque me rompí me cuesta caminar
pero
[Música]
se sostiene
siempre
[Música]
si quiere
ya contamos el me enfrenta
[Música]
mi primo
entonces
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchas gracias eso se llama pasos
no sabemos por este momento de lidiar
que puede hacer las paces con la
universidad porque siempre creí que
tocaba ir como que hacía parte de este
camino que tenemos [ __ ] al frente jardín
colegio universidad marido hijo
ya saben
pero si no pasa nada
esa frase que decía
sabe qué
para lo que estoy hablando
sí
porque los dentistas evoluciones de la
mesa porque si hacer lo que ganará la
verdad es lo máximo es hacer lo que
tengas ganas de hacer
pero seguramente nuestros mapas sino más
en pleno enunciado porque esta frase la
mano a la mandaban como un verdadero
mensaje de lo que te da la gana sino
preocupados porque no hacemos una
reflexión pero nos decían porque la
verdad era que no podía
al decirnos eso
realmente nos estaban de espiritual de
nuestra capacidad de decisión
si no confiaban en nosotros cuando
éramos chiquitos como hacemos seguirán
estar con quieren nosotros mismos y ahí
tengo una pregunta
qué hubiera pasado si nos hubieran
dejado hacer lo que nos daba la gana
seguramente muchos de los que están aquí
no estudian lo que estudian por lo
trabajar en lo que trabajan
y ahora la pena preguntarnos si la
carrera que elegimos por esta vía por
nosotros o por nuestros papás por
ejemplo
las motivaciones bien en lugares
positivos como intereses propios o
negativos como intereses de alguien más
pero es terrible porque nos aferramos a
no intentar cosas nuevas
lo que realmente somos y lo que apasiona
nos hacemos partícipes de nuestro propio
movimiento por eso ahora
voy a contarles una canción que escribí
con esa necesidad de el ser humano de
moverse porque parece que todo está
perfecto pero necesitamos cambiar algo
cuestionar algo
y esta canción se llama movimiento
todo está bien así se supone que debe
ser
[Música]
m
y cambia su forma
sólo espere a un momento
de siempre
i
[Música]
mínimo
a veces cambian las fuerzas que quieras
[Música]
no me atrapan me llevan a besar a sus
pies
no lo sé
y solo queda este elemento
[Música]
no
cambia su forma cambio también sólo
estaré aquí un nombre
sí
[Música]
pero
un momento
pero siempre
[Aplausos]
y gracias
ojalá podemos importar eso que tenemos
dentro liberarnos de todo lo que cree
hemos aprendido cuestionarlo todo hacer
lo que queramos saben qué
hagan lo que se les dé la gana
[Aplausos]